انتكاسة لحزب الله في لبنان
، خسرت مجموعة التراجع
وحلفاؤها انتخابات الأغلبية البرلمانية يوم الأحد ،
مما حقق مكاسب
لمنافسي حزب الله على خلفية
الانهيار الاقتصادي ، وستعرف من خلال
مشاهدة هذا البرنامج أن الأمم المتحدة والبنك الدولي
يلومان حكم لبنان.  نخب
الانهيار الاقتصادي للبلاد
يعتبر من أسوأ الانهيارات في العالم
منذ منتصف القرن التاسع عشر ، لدينا بن
ويدمان يغطي القصة لنا
وهو بالطبع مراسل في
لبنان منذ عقود أه ينضم إلينا الآن
من بيروت.
رأيت الكثير من هذه الدورات ،
أريدك أن تعطيني إحساسًا
بمدى أهمية أننا
رأينا حزب الله فقد مقاعده
أمام أحزاب أكثر ليبرالية أه
أو أحزاب معارضة ، لقد كان
تحولًا رائعًا للأحداث
جيدًا ، إنه أمر مهم  للتأكيد على أن
حزب الله نفسه لم يخسر في الواقع
أي مقاعد ، فإن أعضاء
ائتلافه الذين كانوا تحت البرلمان السابق
لديهم 71 مقعدًا الآن يبدو
أنهم  إلى 60. هذا من أصل 128
مقعدًا في البرلمان اللبناني ، ما رأيناه
هو أن العديد من حلفاء
حزب الله وخاصة المرشحين الموالين لسوريا قد تم
طردهم وكذلك
حليفه المسيحي المسيحي الرئيسي الحركة الوطنية الحرة
كما خسر عددًا من المقاعد
أيضًا.
نظرًا لأن أو ربما أكثر من 12
مرشحًا إصلاحيًا ، فقد حصل العديد منهم
المنتمين إلى انتفاضة أكتوبر 2019
على مقاعد الآن
وهذا تطور مفاجئ
لمجرد أنه خلال الحملة الانتخابية
كان هناك العديد من المرشحين ربما
خمس العدد الإجمالي الذين كانوا
منتسبين أو تم تحديدهم على أنهم مستقلون.
أو منتمين إلى الانتفاضة وكان
الخوف هو أن القوائم الإصلاحية
إذا جاز التعبير كانت كثيرة لدرجة
أنها كانت منقسمة فقط وأن
الأحزاب التقليدية
ستحصل على أصواتها ولكن يبدو
أنهم فعلوا أه بشكل جيد لذا
يبدو  اليوم
أن حزب الله تلقى بعض الضربة
من حيث عدم وجود ائتلاف
أو بالأحرى رئيس برلماني
ائتلاف له أغلبية نيابية
لكن
لبنان يواجه الآن ربما فترة طويلة
من الجمود لأنه لا توجد
كتلة أو تحالف واحد قادر على
الحصول على الأغلبية لذلك نحن في خطر
وجود برلمان معلق واه
حتى في ظل  أفضل الظروف في
السنوات الأخيرة ، لقد استغرق
تشكيل الحكومات وقتًا طويلاً بعد
الانتخابات البرلمانية الأخيرة في مايو 2018
، واستغرق الأمر تسعة أشهر لتشكيل الحكومة المقبلة
ولبنان في هذه المرحلة
في خضم هذه الأزمة الاقتصادية الشديدة
أه أين أنت '  لقد رأينا الناتج المحلي الإجمالي ينخفض
بأكثر من النصف
والبطالة تتصاعد
، وعلى سبيل
المثال لا أستطيع إخباركم بعدد
الأطباء والأساتذة والأشخاص المهرة
الذين غادروا البلاد.
الحكومة المناسبة eleni